I mean I I know there's a number of
deleted scenes on the blu-ray do you
have a favorite deleted scene that is
included here's the thing I don't want
it's not like there was a there's a
director's cut that I just sure make the
film that is out in fact I've been
really lucky at I haven't yet had final
cut but I if I had it they no one would
notice the difference because there's
something like I wanted a guy to smoke
once and that's that's really that's the
extent of it so I've been lucky in the
movies that I've released are basically
my final cut without having had final
cut so the deleted scenes were deleted
for a reason I guess is what I'm saying
sure I liked a lot of the ideas but we
had a year less time on our schedule
and I couldn't tinker with them I if
they didn't immediately serve the movie
that I wanted to make I had to kill him
and move on and then I had characters
that I liked that we never did we had
wanna be superheroes one was called flow
bridge that I really liked and he was
kind of a guy whose power was really
useless raise water out of a bucket and
drop it that's good but heard fun but
but but I thought that was a funny idea
there was a designer who competed who
was mentioned in the film gal Bakke who
was a character we had a scene with
honey you know frozen's wife but they
didn't if they didn't immediately serve
the movie I had to throw them out Bakari
carry mario kario he coming back man you
saw Kerry's parents which was great and
meaning that I was highly entertained by
that situation of seeing Kerry's parents
kind of mad at their daughter being a
little twitchy after the babysitting
assignment you know so so there are a
lot of things presented but it would be
unfair for me to say
they were loaned they they were first
tries at these ideas and then they were
rejected before they were home so it's
kind of like seeing quick something that
was baked that has problems with it but
parts of it are kind of delicious yeah
well then how complete are these deleted
scenes are they just storyboards so did
anything change during the testing
process for the film for you both did
anything get cut during that process no
really I mean it was just kind of
continually every day learning but I
mean I was recutting the film while we
were mixing hmm you know I was saying
hey this shot that'll play better if I
cut this shot in half insert this shot
in between the two and you know it'll
make it pop more so but you know that's
late in the game to be doing that
extract so you know you're fixing stuff
that's going out the door you know so so
that's what cracks me up when some
reviewers are like you know the
motivation for this part was not as
clear as I would like and you're sitting
there going we were under fire you know
Joe's lost an arm you know you know you
don't understand you know and not to say
that we should be cut any slack because
it was a tight experience I'm just
saying it would be nice if we had as
much time as you apparently think we
have to think about it because we were
having to adjust on the fly and make it
as inert sometimes that's good sometimes
a good ratatouille was done fast and and
ratatouille was another experience of
running just 10 you know inches in front
of a freight train if you have too much
time to think about it you know you look
look back at Sodom and you turn into a
pillar or saw what's wife you know but
also you know you have things that you
go I wish I had another two weeks to fix
this plot thing that maybe
as clear as I'd like it to be on the
other hand there are moments that that
if you weren't spontaneous and moving
quickly you would not have them and
they're great moments but they happen
because people are loose and grabbing
for something and and they grab
something great so there are benefits to
moving fast as well
do you read all the reviews of your
movies because they don't help that when
people they don't help when somebody
likes something it doesn't inform me and
when they don't like something it
doesn't inform me the best will best
advice is from other filmmakers and the
audience and the audience responds very
directly when you sit in the theater
with them you can tell when they're
engaged and when they're not and that's
valuable
you